Kevin Costner plays a stern but noble leader
in "Yellowstone" – but how does he treat
the show's cast and crew in real life?
"Yeah?"
Among the band of tough nuts wandering around
in worn-down denim and cowboy hats in Taylor
Sheridan's "Yellowstone," none can hold a
candle to Kevin Costner's John Dutton.
Patriarch of the modern-day Dutton family,
head of the family business, and forceful
overseer of his children's various enterprises,
John Dutton is a man who routinely makes it
clear he is not one to be trifled with lightly.
Given such an effortlessly tough exterior,
it only seems natural for audiences to wonder...
Just how much of John Dutton comes from the
two-time Academy Award-winning star's real
personality?
Ryan Bingham, the actor who plays Walker on
the Emmy-nominated series, might have a potentially
interesting perspective on the matter.
In "Yellowstone," Walker is portrayed as the
odd man out among the various ranch hands
on the Dutton Yellowstone Ranch.
In fact, in Season 2, a particularly nasty
encounter with John Dutton's right-hand man,
Rip Wheeler, nearly results in Walker's untimely
demise.
So, how does Bingham feel about Costner in
real life?
And, perhaps even more importantly, do the
rest of the "Yellowstone" cast ever find themselves
on the receiving end of John Dutton's signature
menacing stare?
Thankfully, the cast and crew of "Yellowstone"
have offered information about Costner that
paints the actor in a decidedly different
manner than that of his stoic on-screen counterpart.
As viewers might have hoped, it doesn't take
long to realize that Costner's "Yellowstone"
persona is firmly confined to the boundaries
of the small screen.
In a wide-ranging interview with the Los Angeles
Times released in February, Bingham covered
a variety of interesting topics related to
himself and his job on the set of "Yellowstone."
Unsurprisingly, he also had good things to
say about his on-screen and off-screen boss.
Bingham revealed that despite John Dutton's
tense nature, the seasoned star behind the
character is actually a legitimate joy to
be around.
In fact, Bingham shared one particular detail
about Costner's on-set behavior that makes
him a true standout in Hollywood.
According to Bingham, Costner insists that
he shake the hand of each and every cast and
crew member every day.
Of course, although John Dutton also seems
like a handshake type of guy, most characters
on the series can never be totally sure that
the hand being offered by Dutton isn't also
gripping a revolver.
While many could likely have guessed it, it's
surely a relief to recognize that Costner
isn't quite so tightly wound up as the character
he portrays.
As the leading man of the series (and an executive
producer too), Costner's behavior on the set
surely lays down a tone for the rest of the
cast and crew to follow.
According to Bingham, people on the set of
"Yellowstone" often feel the freedom to lighten
the mood once the job is done for the day
and the camera is turned off.
Bingham said in the interview,
"We're always joking backstage and things
like that.
It's interesting how light and fun it is when
we're on set and we're playing around.
People are chasing around horses and things
like that.
But then when you see the show, it can be
pretty dark."
Despite the noted difference between the series
and real life, one particularly interesting
aspect that connects the two is Bingham's
penchant for playing the guitar.
Although Lloyd doesn't take too kindly to
Walker's melodies in Season 4, the real-life
crew appears to like it quite a bit.
During a conversation released by Paramount
Network as a "Yellowstone" bonus feature,
a number of "Yellowstone" cast members noted
Bingham's regular use of the guitar on set.
Ian Bohen, the actor who plays Ryan, said
that Bingham plays the guitar "constantly,"
something everyone seems to enjoy.
"He pulls out a guitar, and he'll just get
off in his own world.
And everyone stops what they're doing... and
just listens to it.
It's a dream."
Given all the camaraderie on set in the real
world, perhaps the perennially stressed Dutton
clan could benefit from taking a short trip
out to the bunkhouse too?
Maybe they'll get the chance when Paramount
Network begins airing "Yellowstone" Season
5 at some point later this year.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.